I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, everybody. So if you see a photo of us podcasting, I am now in my husband's closet. Those are not my baseball hats. That is his baseball hat collection. I like to wear baseball hats. You do. You you're sort of like a baseball hat family. I feel like all of your all of your family loves baseball hats. Oh, lady, one Christmas, we were trying to find a family
我是詹娜·菲舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们还是好闺蜜。现在，我们专门为你带来了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当事人才知道的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好。所以，如果你们看到我们录播客的照片，我现在是在我丈夫的衣帽间里。那些不是我的棒球帽。那是他的棒球帽收藏。我喜欢戴棒球帽。你确实喜欢。你们一家可以说是棒球帽世家。我觉得你们全家人都很喜欢棒球帽。哦，天哪，有一年圣诞节，我们想找一张全家
photo that we could put on our Christmas card. And I couldn't find one where one of us wasn't wearing a hat. And so we decided to make it a bit. And we did a collage of the just a baseball hat Christmas card. My mother-in-law was mortified, mortified. She's like, why are you all in hat? Yes, baseball hats for your formal Christmas card. But yeah, it was like an inside joke. We're a hat family. We would fit in very well in Josh's closet, I guess is what I'm saying. I think you would. By the way, side note, your Christmas cards are always awesome. My favorite, and I have it hanging up in the kitchen still is the one where you guys are all holding sunny your cat. Oh, yes. That was another
照放到圣诞贺卡上。结果我找不到一张我们之中没有一个人戴帽子的照片。于是我们决定把它当成一个梗。我们做了一张全是棒球帽的拼图圣诞贺卡。我婆婆当时惊呆了，简直惊呆了。她问：“为什么你们所有人都在戴帽子？”没错，竟然把棒球帽当成正式的圣诞贺卡照片。不过，这就像是个内部笑话。我们是个帽子世家。我想这就是我想表达的，我们和乔治的衣帽间简直绝配。我觉得确实如此。顺便说一句，插一句，你们的圣诞贺卡总是棒极了。我最喜欢的一张，现在还挂在厨房里呢，就是你们所有人抱着你们的猫桑尼的那张。哦，对。那又是另一
fun collage. We had a good time with that. Lee has sunny on his head. I'm holding sunny upside down. It was a good one. Thanks, lady. You guys have a floppy cat and floppy cats are so great in photos. My cats would have like shredded our heads. Look, if we tried that. Okay, okay. So here we go. What are we doing today, Jenna? Today, we are talking about season three, episode 12, traveling salesmen. Oh, it's so good. It's so good. I rewatched this one and the return with my kids. We all snuggled up in bed and watched them. They were laughing hysterically. Well, Angela, it's a good thing you watch those together. I did too because they were actually created to be kind of one big episode to be
张有趣的拼图。我们当时玩得很开心。李把桑尼顶在头上。我把桑尼倒过来抱。那张真的很不错。谢谢你，亲爱的。你们有一只软绵绵的猫，而且软绵绵的猫拍照时实在太棒了。如果我们尝试那样做，我的猫大概会把我们的头都抓破吧。好吧，好吧。那么我们开始吧。詹娜，我们今天要做什么？今天，我们要聊的是第三季第十二集，外勤推销员。哦，这一集太棒了。太棒了。我和孩子们一起重温了这一集和《回归》篇。我们一起蜷缩在床上看。他们笑得前仰后合。好吧，安吉拉，你能一起看完这些真是太好了。我也看了，因为这两集原本就是作为一个超长的大剧集来制作并
watched together. And that is why they were written by three writers, Mike Sher, Lee Eisenberg and Jean Stupnitsky. And both of those episodes were directed by Greg Daniels. All right, Jenna, well, why don't you hit us with a summary? All right. So in traveling salesmen, because that's the episode we're covering today, Dwight covers for Angela after she misses an important deadline. The sales team all pair up for sales calls. But at the same time, Angela uncharacteristically invites Pam to coffee and then discusses her love life in code, but she discusses her love life. And then upon the return of the sales team, Michael learns that Dwight went to corporate behind his back. He doesn't know why Dwight quits Dunder Mifflin. Yes. And then Karen
连起来看的。正因如此，它由三位编剧共同撰写：迈克·谢尔、李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯普涅茨基。这两集都是由格雷格·丹尼尔斯执导的。好了，詹娜，要不你来给我们做个总结吧？好的。那么在《外勤推销员》这一集里，也就是我们主要讨论的这一集，德怀特在安吉拉错过了一个重要截止日期后替她顶包。销售团队都两两配对去进行销售拜访。但与此同时，安吉拉反常地邀请帕姆去喝咖啡，然后用暗语讨论她的感情生活，不过她确实讨论了她的感情生活。接着，等销售团队返回后，迈克尔得知德怀特越过他直接去找了总公司。他不知道德怀特为什么要离开邓德·米夫林。没错。然后凯伦
finds out that Jim once had a thing for Pam. That's a lot of stuff. That's a lot of stuff. Phyllis, man. She spilled the beans. I know. Phyllis. Phyllis. Okay, we'll get to that. We'll get to that. I bet you have some really good fast facts. Well, you know I do because you know that we got something. We did. All right. So here's what we got. All right. Fast fact number one, like I said, both this and the next episode, the return were written and treated like one big episode. They were both directed by Greg Daniels. What do we do, Ange? Tell everybody what we did. We reached out to Greg and he sent in audio clips and they are fantastic. And now Jen and I want him to send in audio clips every single week.
发现吉姆曾经对帕姆动过心。这信息量可真大。信息量太大了。菲利斯，天哪。她把秘密全说出去了。我知道。菲利斯。菲利斯。好吧，我们待会儿会聊到这个。我们待会儿会聊到这个。我敢打赌你准备了一些非常精彩的快讯。好吧，你知道我当然有，因为你知道我们有备而来。我们确实有。好吧，这就是我们准备的内容。好吧，快讯第一条，就像我说的，这一集和下一集《回归》都是作为一整集来编写和对待的。它们都是由格雷格·丹尼尔斯执导的。我们做了什么，安吉拉？告诉大家我们做了什么。我们联系了格雷格，他发来了音频剪辑，太棒了。现在詹娜和我希望他每周都发音频剪辑。
Yes. His audio clips are so good. You guys were giddy about them. So the first thing we asked him was what was the inspiration for this episode? And here is what he had to say. Travis Salesman and the return is a little two episode arc that we did as part of the working out of the merger of the two branches stories. Andy was always conceived in Gay Witch Hunt to be the Stanford version of Dwight. So it was natural that they butt heads when the branches merged. And we liked the idea that Dwight, as the hometown favorite, gets to have a really strong and romantic arc here. You see a very noble side of him protecting
是的。他的音频剪辑太棒了。你们之前对它们赞不绝口。所以我们问他的第一个问题是，这一集的灵感来源是什么？以下是他的回答。《外勤推销员》和《回归》是我们为处理两家分公司合并故事而制作的一个小两集故事线。安迪在《盖伊万圣节》中最初的构思就是斯坦福版的德怀特。所以当两家分公司合并时，他们针锋相对是很自然的。我们喜欢这样一个设定：德怀特作为本地最受欢迎的人，在这里有一条非常强烈的浪漫故事线。你会看到他非常高尚的一面，那就是保护
the woman that he loves. And I think one of the reasons we made it two episodes was it didn't didn't feel real to me or earned to have him leave and come back in only one episode. So it just felt a lot better to spread it out over two. And another part about that storyline was that it was pairings. And you know, a writing exercise that I often did with the writers was I'd have them try and come up with pairings of characters that we hadn't had scenes together before. And so this entire episode was fun pairings like Ryan and Stanley or Phyllis and Karen. And of course, Angela and Pam, who have a great emotional storyline where they really are kind of growing as friends. And it was really
他所深爱的女人。我想我们把它拍成两集的原因之一是，如果只用一集就让他离开然后又回来，这对我来说感觉不够真实，也没有说服力。所以把剧情分散到两集里会好得多。这条故事线的另一个部分是角色配对。你知道，我经常和编剧们做一个写作练习，就是让他们尝试想出一些以前没有对手戏的角色组合。所以整集都是有趣的配对，比如瑞恩和斯坦利，或者菲利斯和凯伦。当然还有安吉拉和帕姆，他们有一条伟大的情感故事线，彼此作为朋友真正成长了。而且看到
cool to see Jim and Dwight, too, and see their backstory. And then the other thing about Traveling Salesman was we used in the client, we used being good at sales to make Michael more likable. And right, you know, in Traveling Salesman, you see a whole bunch of different characters and how they are as salespeople. And you see how how great Jim and Dwight work together. And Michael being like a straight man for Andy, who's just terrible. And so it kind of helps distinguish the more likable original Dwight versus the more sinister, schemy, you know, new Dwight. Keep talking, talk forever, Greg. Greg, talk forever. It's so fascinating. I loved it.
吉姆和德怀特在一起，了解他们的过去，也很酷。关于《外勤推销员》，另一件事是，我们在《客户》中利用擅长销售这一点让迈克尔更讨人喜欢。而你知道，在《外勤推销员》中，你会看到一大群不同的角色以及他们作为推销员的表现。你会看到吉姆和德怀特的合作是多么默契。而迈克尔则像是安迪的陪衬，而安迪简直糟透了。所以这有助于区分更讨人喜欢的原版德怀特与更加阴险、喜欢密谋的新德怀特。继续说，永远说下去，格雷格。格雷格，永远说下去。太迷人了。我太喜欢了。
Not only were there these new pairings of characters, but also of writers. It's just so interesting. Yes. Yes, and so much comes out in this episode when you put these different people together for the first time, really. Yeah. So you guys, I don't know if we need to start some sort of a petition, but we really want to create a new feature of the show called inspiration with Greg. And he will send us an audio clip of the inspiration behind every episode. And there's like piano music. Greg will tell us the inspiration. And then Kent tells us the nuts and bolts of how he made that inspiration happen. Greg is listening right now. And I was like, ladies, what are you signing me up for? Exactly. What is fast
不仅有这些新的角色配对，还有编剧的配对。这太有趣了。是的，是的，当你第一次把这些不同的人真正聚在一起时，这一集里会迸发出如此多的看点。是的。所以大家，我不知道我们是否需要发起某种请愿，但我们真的很想为这个节目创造一个名为“格雷格的灵感”的新板块。他将给我们发送一段音频剪辑，讲述每一集背后的灵感。背景里还会有钢琴音乐。格雷格会告诉我们灵感来源。然后肯会告诉我们他是如何将这个灵感付诸实现的具体细节。格雷格现在正在听呢。当时我就想：女士们，你们这是把我套进什么里去了？没错。第二条快讯
fact number two? Well, Angela, speaking of Kentopedia, fast fact number two is called locations, locations, locations. So for this episode, because we actually shot it in conjunction with the return, we did something called crossboarding. It's a little lingo that they use in the biz. Lingo alert. Show this lingo alert. So crossboarding is when you shoot two episodes at once. We normally shot one episode each week, but we shot these episodes over a 10 day period from October 16th, 2006 to October 27th, 2006. And the main reason for this was because of locations. We just had a lot of places to go in these two episodes and having the flexibility to shoot it over a two week period was really helpful. Yes.
是什么？好吧，安吉拉，说到肯百科，第二条快讯叫做“地点，地点，地点”。对于这一集，因为我们实际上是与《回归》同时拍摄的，所以我们做了一件叫做“交叉拍摄”的事情。这是他们在圈内使用的一个小行话。行话警报。快出示这个行话警报。所以交叉拍摄是指同时拍摄两集。我们通常每周拍摄一集，但我们在2006年10月16日到2006年10月27日的10天时间里拍摄了这两集。这样做的主要原因是为了取景地。我们在这两集里有太多的地方要去，能够灵活地在两周内完成拍摄真的很有帮助。是的。
And they would also do a thing, you guys, they call it shooting out a location. So for example, every scene that happened in that coffee shop, they would film in one day and then they could close out that location. They don't have to pay for that location for multiple days. So sometimes when you crossboard, it's a great way to save money because you can shoot out a location. Yes. Have we bored you to tears with a little behind the scenes lingo. Lingo alert, shoot out a location. So since you brought up the coffee shop, Angela, we had a fan question from Brianna Kernan, Harshita Verma and Molly Ottawa. Did Pam and Angela go to the same coffee shop that Jim and Karen end up going to later and is the coffee shop
而且大家知道，他们还会做一件事，他们称之为“拍光某个取景地”。例如，发生在那个咖啡馆里的每一场戏，他们会在一天内拍完，然后就可以彻底收回这个取景地了。他们不需要为这个取景地支付多天的费用。所以有时候交叉拍摄是省钱的好方法，因为你可以一次性拍完一个地点。是的。我们用一点幕后行话把你无聊透顶了吗？行话警报，“拍光取景地”。既然你提到了咖啡馆，安吉拉，我们有一个来自布里安娜·克南、哈希塔·韦尔玛和莫莉·渥太华的粉丝提问。帕姆和安吉拉去的咖啡馆，跟后来吉姆和凯伦去的咖啡馆是同一家吗？而且这个咖啡馆
location the same one used in later episodes? Yes. Yes and yes. Yes and yes. And here's a little tidbit, Jenna. I don't know if you remember that coffee shop was next door to the place we filmed the tattoo parlor scene. What? Yes. An upcoming episode with Andy that tattoo parlor was next to the coffee shop. It must be some little strip mall that Ken just had good favor with. So he was like, okay, we'll take that. We'll take that. Well, here's what Kent told me. He said the coffee shop was a real location. We filmed at a place called Java Groove Coffee. It was on Victory Boulevard in Van Nuys. Yes. However, it has been closed and replaced by a printing company. So I'm sorry if you come to LA, you cannot
取景地跟后面剧集里用的是同一个吗？是的。是的，没错。是的，没错。这里有个小花絮，詹娜。我不知道你记不记得，那家咖啡馆隔壁就是我们拍摄纹身店场景的地方。什么？是的。后面有一集安迪去的那家纹身店就在咖啡馆旁边。那一定是个小商业街，肯跟那里的人关系很好。所以他说，好吧，我们就用这个。好吧，我们就用那个。嗯，肯是这么对我说他说咖啡馆是个真实的取景地。我们在一个叫“爪哇律动咖啡”的地方拍的。它在范内司的胜利大道上。是的。不过，它已经倒闭了，现在变成了一家印刷公司。所以很抱歉，如果你来洛杉矶，你不能
get a cup of coffee anymore at Java Groove Coffee. Well, we'll have to find out if they can get a tattoo next door still. Yes, perhaps. What a fun office set tour that would be. You could go see the outside of Dunder Mifflin, grab a cup of coffee and get a tattoo. I mean, if you're a diehard fan, right? Yep. But now you can just get something printed and then get a tattoo. All right. Well, I am not done talking about FastFact number two, Angela. Oh, I'm sorry. There's more locations. We have so many more locations. This is a question from Kylan Hadley and Jordan Simpson. Were all the sets that the salesman traveled to local office buildings or were they built in the warehouse set, like the fancy Stanford
再去爪哇律动咖啡喝一杯咖啡了。好吧，我们得去查查看他们隔壁现在还能不能纹身。是的，也许吧。那将是一次多么有趣的办公室取景地之旅啊。你可以去看看邓德·米夫林的门脸，喝杯咖啡再去纹身。我的意思是，如果你是个铁杆粉丝的话，对吧？没错。但现在你只能去复印点东西，然后再去纹身了。好吧，关于第二条快讯，我还没说完呢，安吉拉。哦，对不起。还有更多的取景地。我们还有更多的取景地。这是来自凯兰·哈德利和乔丹·斯普林逊的提问。推销员们去过的所有外景都是当地的办公楼，还是像豪华的斯坦福分公司那样在仓库布景里搭建的？
branch was? All right. Are you ready? Mm hmm. They were not a set. They were a location, but they were all the same location. Here's what they did. The building where Jim and Dwight are in the parking lot and Dwight's like pumping himself up. That was in Van Nuys. It was at the Panorama Medical Plaza. Plaza, St. Louis. Was it at the Plaza? It was at the Plaza. Oh my gosh. That's so St. Louis. Saints. Oh my gosh. I have a St. Louis catch later in the episode, but that's that's the first one. Plaza, Plaza. So at the Panorama Medical Plaza, they found a completely vacant floor and they dressed five different spaces to be the various offices that everyone visits. Isn't that amazing? They took one location
好了。准备好了吗？嗯哼。它们不是布景。它们是一个取景地，但它们都是同一个取景地。事情是这样的。吉姆和德怀特在停车场的那栋楼，德怀特当时在给自己打气。那是在范内司。它在全景医疗广场。广场，圣路易斯。它在广场吗？它在广场。哦，天哪。太圣路易斯了。圣徒。哦，天哪。我在这集的后面还会讲到一个关于圣路易斯的梗，但这是第一个。广场，广场。所以，在全景医疗广场，他们找到了一整层空置的楼层，并将五个不同的空间布置成了大家拜访的各个办公室。这不是很神奇吗？他们利用了一个取景地
and made it five different places, but there's more. Oh, more? So you know how we said we shot these two episodes together in the next episode, the return. At the beginning, you see Dwight going around with his resume. Two of those offices were also part of the Panorama Medical Building. That Plaza covered a lot of ground, lady. So much Plaza. So one thing, the church scenes with Stanley and Ryan, those were filmed at the Panorama Presbyterian Church on Roscoe. So that was another separate location and then there's even staples, but we'll talk about that next week. So many locations. So many. All right. I think we've covered all the locations. Let's move on to fast fact number three. Another fan question. Okay,
把它变成了五个不同的地方，但还没完呢。哦，还有？所以你知道我们之前说过这两集是一起拍的，在下一集《回归》里。开头你会看到德怀特拿着简历四处奔走。其中两个办公室也是全景医疗大楼的一部分。那个广场占地面积可真大啊，亲爱的。太壮观了。所以还有一件事，斯坦利和瑞恩的教堂场景，那是在罗斯科的全景长老会教堂拍摄的。所以那是另一个独立的取景地，然后甚至还有史泰博中心，但我们下周再聊这个。取景地太多了。太多了。好吧，我想我们已经把所有取景地都聊完了。让我们进入第三条快讯。又是一个粉丝提问。好吧，
guys, we love your questions. They are so helpful in structuring the podcast. Thank you. All right. Fan question Rachel Labish and Rebecca Kelly said, I noticed a weird discrepancy between the Netflix episodes and the DVD episodes. In the DVD episodes, there is a whole subplot about Pam winning an art contest. In the Netflix version of the episode, the whole thing is cut out. I haven't been able to find anything online about it. Do you know why this is? Ladies, that is a fantastic question because this whole podcast almost went haywire because Jenna was watching the Netflix episode and I was watching the DVD episode and they're totally different. Angela and I were so confused because we were trying
大家，我们很喜欢你们的提问。它们对我们构建播客结构非常有帮助。谢谢你们。好的。粉丝提问，蕾切尔·拉比什和丽贝卡·凯利说，我注意到Netflix播出的版本和DVD播出的版本之间有一个奇怪的出入。在DVD版本中，有一整条关于帕姆赢得艺术比赛的副线剧情。而在Netflix版本的这一集中，整段内容都被剪掉了。我在网上找不到任何相关的资料。你知道这是为什么吗？女士们，这是一个非常棒的问题，因为这个播客差点就乱套了，因为詹娜看的是Netflix的版本，而我看的是DVD版本，它们完全不同。安吉拉和我都感到非常困惑，因为我们当时正在梳理
to outline this episode and there were all these scenes that Angela was talking about that I remembered shooting Angela, but that weren't in the version I was watching. Yeah. So I started digging around and here is what I found out. On March 15, 2007, NBC aired a repeat of this episode, but they didn't want to air an exact repeat. They wanted to get more viewers. So they called it a new Pete. A new Pete. You know, when they would run repeats, they wouldn't get as many viewers, which meant fewer ad dollars for commercials, right? Because that's how networks make money. So they thought if we add a new Pete where it's mostly the old episode, but then some stuff you've never seen before, maybe it would up the viewership and that's why
这一集的大纲，安吉拉提到的那些场景，我都记得我们拍过，安吉拉，但它们根本不在我看的那个版本里。所以，我开始到处深挖，以下是我发现的情况。2007年3月15日，全国广播公司（NBC）重播了这一集，但他们不想只播出一场原封不动重播。他们希望能吸引更多观众。所以他们管这叫“新重播”。新重播。你知道，当他们重播旧节目时，收看的人不会那么多，这意味着广告商的广告收入就会减少，对吧？因为电视台就是靠这个赚钱的。所以他们想，如果我们加入一些“新重播”的内容，大部分是旧剧集，但再穿插一些你从未见过的新内容，也许就能提高收视率，这就是为什么
there are now like these two different versions of this episode living out in the world. Because of some somebody in marketing at NBC came up with this new Pete idea. I don't think we ever did that again. I think this is our one and only new Pete. Am I right? Well, I guess it happens again in season four. Oh, when Phyllis tells Jim about her house that Bob bought her, it's on the DVD, but it's cut out of the Netflix version. So here's what's on the DVD. First of all, traveling salesmen in the return are one episode on the DVD. They're not two episodes. They're one like super sized huge episode. Crazy, right? Crazy. But in the traveling salesman, these are the scenes you missed if you watched it on Netflix. Pam gets a phone call that a watercolor she made won
现在世界上会存在这一集的两个不同版本。因为NBC市场部的某个人想出了这个“新重播”的点子。我想我们再也没有那样做过。我觉得这是我们绝无仅有的一次“新重播”。我没说错吧？好吧，我猜第四季里又发生过一次。哦，当菲利斯向吉姆提起鲍勃给她买的那栋房子时，DVD里有这段，但Netflix版本里被剪掉了。所以DVD里的内容是这样的。首先，在DVD里，《外勤推销员》和《回归》合并成了一集。它们不是两集。它们是一集超长的大剧集。很疯狂，对吧？太疯狂了。但在《外勤推销员》中，如果你在Netflix上观看，这些是你错过的场景：帕姆接到一个电话，说她画的一幅水彩画赢得了
a sixth grade elementary school art contest. I remember shooting it. These sixth graders picked your art. You were really excited. You won $100. You were really excited to tell Kevin about it. Kevin's like, yeah, well, I won $400 betting on a Celtics game. And you were like, okay, thanks for that, Kevin. And then she tells Angela. Pam is just desperate to tell someone that her art won and no one's in the office. They're all out on a sales call. So she pops up over the partition. Jenna, we have one of those classic over the partition, Angela and Pam scenes. And she tells Angela, and Angela has all this good favor in her heart towards Pam right now. You know, they've gone and got coffee. They've bonded. And so Angela goes, congratulations. And
六年级小学艺术比赛的奖项。我记得我们拍过这个。这群六年级学生挑中了你的画。你当时超级兴奋。你赢了一百块钱。你迫不及待地想把这事告诉凯文。凯文却说：“哦，好吧，我在凯尔特人的比赛上赌博赢了四百块呢。”而你的反应是：“好吧，谢谢你啊，凯文。”然后她告诉了安吉拉。帕姆现在太渴望找个人分享她的艺术作品获奖的喜悦了，然而办公室里一个人都没有。他们都出去拜访客户了。所以她从隔板探出头来。詹娜，我们有一个经典的帕姆和安吉拉隔板探头对手戏。她把这事告诉了安吉拉，而安吉拉此时对帕姆心里有着各种好感。你知道的，他们一起去喝过咖啡。他们感情加深了。所以安吉拉说：“恭喜你。”然后
then she says, I really like having these little moments with you. And then she offers Pam, Pam, one of her kittens, Sprinkles has had kittens, and she offers Pam the dominant male named Ash. And Pam clearly does not want this cat. She makes up excuses. She's like, oh, you know, my landlord, it's just, it's a thing. And, you know, it'd be, I don't know. And Angela is like, F you. She instantly goes back to being just this cold snarky person to Pam. That's it. Their friendship's over. It was so fleeting. And then lastly, when Jim finally comes back from his sales call, Pam is so excited to tell him, and he's on his way out to have coffee with Karen. And Pam's like, Jim, and he starts talking to her about it. And Karen's like,
她说：“我很喜欢和你这样共度的短暂时光。”接着她问帕姆，帕姆要不要她的一只小猫，小花的猫生了一窝小猫，她问帕姆要不要那只名叫“灰烬”的霸道公猫。而帕姆显然不想要这只猫。她找了各种借口。她说：“哦，你知道的，我的房东，这事有点麻烦。而且，这会……我不知道。”而安吉拉则是一句“去你的”。她瞬间又恢复成了对帕姆冷酷刻薄的样子。就这样。他们的友谊结束了。真是昙花一现。最后，当吉姆终于结束销售拜访回来时，帕姆兴奋极了，想把这事告诉他，但他正准备出去和凯伦喝咖啡。帕姆喊道：“吉姆——”而他却开始跟她聊起别的。凯伦则说：“
we're going to get coffee. So it's this awkward moment. I remember shooting all of that. Here's the other thing I found really interesting. So in the opening scene of the Netflix version, it's Harvey, the computer, right? Yeah. Talking to Jim. That's in the deleted scenes on the DVD. That's not even in the episode. Oh, so I, because I was wondering, well, what did they cut out of the episode in order to make room for Pam's art contest? So there must be things when they aired this on NBC, there must be things missing. In the deleted scenes on the DVD, there's a lot of extra scenes in the cars driving. Yeah. Lots of extra driving scenes. And then there's this Harvey, the talking computer. That's a deleted scene. Wow. So there you go. We are going to be following
我们要去喝咖啡了。”所以这是一个非常尴尬的时刻。我记得我们拍了所有这些内容。我还发现了一件非常有趣的事。在Netflix版本的开场戏里，那是电脑哈维，对吧？对。在跟吉姆说话。那是DVD里的被删减片段。它甚至都不在正片里。哦，所以我当时就在想，为了给帕姆的艺术比赛腾出空间，他们到底从这一集中剪掉了什么？所以当NBC播出时，肯定有些内容不见了。在DVD的被删减片段里，有很多开车过程中的额外戏份。是的。有很多额外的开车场景。然后还有这个会说话的电脑哈维。那是一个被删减片段。哇哦。所以就是这样。我们打算
along the Netflix airing because that way our time codes will match up. But that's what you will get if you go to the DVDs. I love it. I love it. I feel like I'm really happy with all of that. I think we should take a break and then come back and break down the episode. Sounds great. All right, we're back. Let's dive right in this episode. Michael is really excited to show Jim and Pam his new computer. It's his buddy, his talking friend, Harvey. Oh my gosh. And basically, he types into the keyboard and then Harvey says stuff. Yes. And he's made the back of the computer like a face. Like he used some post-it notes. Like he's, anyway, Harvey is this talking computer. Well, we got a fan question from Bailey Aspinson, Becky Gemmel, Megan Keele, Chelsea Lane,
跟着Netflix播出的版本走，因为这样我们的时间码才能对上。但如果你去看DVD，就会看到那些内容。我喜欢。我太喜欢了。我觉得我对这一切都非常满意。我想我们应该休息一下，然后再回来剖析这一集。听起来不错。好了，我们回来了。让我们直接深入这一集。迈克尔非常兴奋地向吉姆和帕姆展示他的新电脑。那是他的好哥们，他的会说话的朋友，哈维。哦，天哪。基本上，他在键盘上打字，然后哈维就会说话。是的。他还把电脑背面弄得像张脸一样。就像他用了几张便利贴。不管怎样，哈维就是这台会说话的电脑。嗯，我们收到了来自贝利·阿斯平森、贝基·格梅尔、梅根·基尔、切尔西·莱恩
and Alyssa Sorensen. Everyone wants to know who is the voice of Harvey? Oh, that's a great question. Who is it? I recognized it immediately. And did you recognize it, Angela? Oh, no, I didn't. Oh, no. As soon as I heard the voice, I was like, oh, it's Mike Scherr. Oh my gosh. That's such a great cat. So I emailed him and he was like, yes, it's me. I was Harvey. So he's the one that said, me so horny, me love you long Tim. Yes, exactly. And Pam's like, oh, I'd love to meet long Tim. The way you and John played off Steve in that scene made me laugh so hard because Michael's just gets so frustrated that you guys aren't thinking his talking computer is amazing. Well, some people notice that when we cut away to Michael's screen, what he's been typing doesn't
和阿丽莎·索伦森的粉丝提问。每个人都想知道哈维的配音是谁？哦，这是一个好问题。是谁配的？我一下子就听出来了。安吉拉，你听出来了吗？哦，没有，我没听出来。哦，不。我一听到那个声音，就想：“哦，是迈克·谢尔。”哦，天哪。这真是个极好的彩蛋。所以我给他发了电子邮件，他回信说：“是的，是我。我就是哈维。”所以就是他说出了那句：“我好寂寞，我想爱你很久，蒂姆。”是的， exactamente。帕姆说：“哦，我很想见见很久以前的蒂姆。”你和约翰在那个场景里配合史蒂夫的表演让我笑得前仰后合，因为迈克尔变得极其沮丧，因为你们俩觉得他的会说话的电脑一点也不神奇。嗯，有些人注意到，当我们切到迈克尔的电脑屏幕时，他一直在打的字与你听到的并不
quite match with what you've been hearing. That's just because the scene was longer. And we actually did have Harvey say all those lines and we had lines, but then in the editing room, they cut some of them out. So the screen was indicative of the scene as written and it got a little trimmed down in the editing room. So that's why his screen doesn't quite match. Some really good fan catches right away. I know. All right. So now Angela, we move over to accounting and Kevin tells Angela that corporate did not receive their tax forms. But Angela says, no, no, they arrived this morning and he wants you to know how very important this is. Angela, here's what I wrote down when I watched this scene. What? WTF is up with your hair. Why do you have a flower of hair on the back of your
完全吻合。那只是因为原本的场景更长一些。我们实际上确实让哈维把所有的台词都说了出来，我们也有对应的台词，但在剪辑室里，他们把其中的一些剪掉了。所以屏幕上的文字是剧本中原本的场景，而在剪辑室里稍微精简了一下。这就是为什么他的屏幕显示与声音不太匹配的原因。有一些非常棒的粉丝立刻就发现了这些彩蛋。我知道。好吧，现在安吉拉，我们来到会计部，告诉安吉拉公司没有收到他们的税务表格。但安吉拉却说：“不，不，它们今天早上刚到。”而且他想让你知道这件事有多么重要。安吉拉，当我看到这个场景时，我写下的是：
head? Guys, I'm going to I took a picture and I'm going to post it because it's insanity. What is happening? When we got the script, Kim Ferry and I started talking. Kim is who did our hair and we were like, you know, Angela is happy in this episode. Now she starts out in the morning a little worried, right? Did Dwight make it? Is everything going to be okay? But she's a lady in love and her man has done this amazingly gallant thing for her. And I feel like she's sort of dressing the part of like this lady in love. She's wearing her Janet Jackson Rhythm Nation mini short sleeve jacket. That's made a callback. And she did a little something extra fancy with her hair. Kim and I just thought maybe she's just she's taken it up a notch. Yeah, she turned her hair into a
什么？你这头发到底是怎么回事？为什么你脑后顶着一朵花形状的头发？大家，我要拍张照发出来，因为这太疯狂了。这到底是怎么回事？当我们拿到剧本时，金·费里和我开始讨论。金是负责我们发型的人，我们当时想：“你知道的，安吉拉这一集心情很好。虽然她早上开始时有点担心，对吧？德怀特成功了吗？一切都会顺利吗？”但她是个坠入爱河的女人，而且她的男人为她做了一件如此惊艳、英勇的事情。我觉得她有点像是在打扮成坠入爱河的女人的样子。她穿着她珍妮·杰克逊《节奏国度》风格的迷你短袖夹克。这是一个经典的致敬。而且她的头发还做了一些格外花哨的处理。金和我当时就觉得，也许她只是把造型升级了一下。是的，她把头发变成了一个
pinwheel flower. And clearly she has eight arms and multiple mirrors. Because how do you do that to the back of your head? Well, when I saw that hair, all I could think about was, oh my gosh, she couldn't lay down during her breaks. Because sometimes at lunch, I would want to, you know, lay back after I eat, maybe snooze it out because we would get up real early. Sometimes I need a little snooze at lunch. But you, you couldn't do that that week, I guess, can lay on that. That would be so uncomfortable. I couldn't even lean back on a chair, lady. I couldn't even recline in any way. Guys, check it out. You don't have to look hard. It's insane. It's also amazing. We had a lot of people write in Julia Lee, Bethany Devish,
风车花。而且很显然她有八只手和好几面镜子。因为你怎么能在自己脑袋后面弄出那种发型？嗯，当我看到那个发型时，我脑子里想的全部都是：“哦，天哪，她在休息的时候肯定没法躺下来。”因为有时候在午饭后，我可能会想要，你知道的，吃完后躺一会儿，也许打个盹，因为我们起得非常早。有时候我午饭后需要小睡一会儿。但是你，你那周肯定做不到这一点，没法躺在那上面。那该有多不舒服啊。我连靠在椅子上都做不到，亲爱的。我根本没法以任何方式向后靠。大家，去看看吧。你们不用仔细找。这太疯狂了。同时也太神奇了。我们有很多观众写信来，朱莉·李、贝瑟尼·德维什、
Kaylee Wading, Anita Prasad. They all said Angela's hair looks incredible in this episode. Thank you. Thank you very much. And now we're going to come up onto this talking head that Rashida actually mentioned when she was a guest on Benihana, where Andy talks about him and Karen being the last two left standing, right? And Andy says he's not going to be one of the kids touring Willy Wonka's factory. He will not fall into the chocolate river. I loved that reference. I loved it too. But all I could think about, Jenna, is that he does fall into the lake. When? At beach games. Totally forgot that. He falls into the lake. He's in a giant sumo suit and he floats on by. And I couldn't help but think what an amazing like callback to the
凯莉·韦丁、安妮塔·普拉萨德。他们都说安吉拉的发型在这集里看起来棒极了。谢谢你们。非常感谢。现在我们要进入这个谈话访谈环节了，也就是热希达在做客节目时提到的那一集，安吉拉谈到她和凯伦是最后剩下的两个人，对吧？安吉拉说她可不会成为参观威利·旺卡工厂的孩子之一。她绝不会掉进巧克力河里。我太喜欢这个梗了。我也很喜欢。但我满脑子想的都是，詹娜，他确实掉进湖里了。什么时候？在海滩运动会上。完全忘了这事了。他掉进湖里了。他穿着巨大的相扑服，漂浮着过去了。我忍不住觉得这真是一个绝妙的
Willy Wonka River thing. I don't know. I thought that was kind of fun. Oh my God. Yeah. I totally, yes. I'm so sorry. It's all coming back to me. We'll get to it when we talk about beach games. But yes, Ed slowly floating away. I remember it now so clearly. So Angela, now you're standing at reception. You're getting yourself some jelly beans and Dwight comes in. It's so sweet. He lets you know the tax forms have been delivered. Yeah. You guys are kind of talking in code, but of course, Pam is clocking it all. And then as you walk away, you say, I don't want these and you leave the jelly beans. We had a fan question. Okay. Ally Joe Higginbotham says, did Angela improv that line? I don't want these to Pam after she took the jelly beans. Yes. Yes, I did.
对威利·旺卡巧克力河梗的致敬。我不知道。我觉得这挺有趣的。哦，天哪。是的。我完全，是的。太抱歉了。我想起来了。等我们聊到海滩运动会时再细说。不过是的，埃德慢慢漂走的画面。我现在想得太清楚了。所以安吉拉，现在你站在前台。你在拿果冻豆吃，而德怀特进来了。太甜了。他告诉你税务表格已经送到了。是的。你们俩在用暗语聊天，不过当然了，帕姆把这一切都看在眼里。然后当你走开时，你说：“我不要这些了”，并把果冻豆留在了那里。我们有一个粉丝提问。好吧。
The note that Greg had given me in that scene is that, you know, I'm so anxious to talk to Dwight to find out that everything went okay, but I had to make some business for myself. Like, why would I be at reception? So I decided to kind of dig in the jelly beans. I just sort of was like, oh, this is what I'll do. So I was digging in the jelly beans and I put a few in my hand throughout the scene. And then as Dwight walked away, I just had them in my hand. So I just placed them on the countertop like your kid would. I don't like this. Yes. Just walked away. And it just tickled us so much and they left it in. But the part I love even more Jenna is your look, your look of like, it said so much to me in the moment. It said people leave their water bottles and their trash
阿莉·乔·希金伯顿说：“安吉拉对帕姆说‘我不要这些了’是即兴发挥吗？”是的。是的，我是即兴的。格雷格在那场戏中给我的提示是，你知道的，我非常急于和德怀特说话，想确认一切是否顺利，但我必须给自己找点事做。比如，我为什么会站在前台？所以我决定假装在果冻豆里挑拣。我当时就想：哦，这就是我要做的。所以我在果冻豆里翻找，在整场戏中我手里抓了几颗。然后当德怀特走开时，它们还在我手里。所以我只是像个小孩子一样把它们放在了柜台上。我才不要这个。是的。就这样走开了。这把我们逗得不行，他们就把这个镜头留下了。但我更喜欢的部分是你的表情，詹娜，你的表情。那一刻它说明了太多问题。它给我的感觉是：
on my desk all the time. After you would leave the jelly beans, I added a little bit that got cut out and probably it should have been cut out because it just would have gone on forever. But I would find all these various ways to get rid of the jelly beans. So I remember one time I picked up the trash can and I scooched them into the trash can using a piece of paper. And another time I like took a tissue and I picked them up with a tissue. And another time I think I picked them up and put them back in the jelly bean container. I know I had all these ways that I got rid of these jelly beans. And I had a good time with that. None of them made it in, of course, but it was just kind of like a fun little bit we were doing. So should we move into the conference room now,
人们总是把水瓶和垃圾留在我的桌子上。在你留下果冻豆之后，我加了一小段后来被剪掉的内容，也许本来就该剪掉，因为那样就会没完没了了。但我会想出各种各样的方法来处理掉那些果冻豆。我记得有一次我拿起垃圾桶，用一张纸把它们扫进了垃圾桶。还有一次我拿了一张纸巾，用纸巾把它们捡起来。还有一次我想我把它们捡起来放回了果冻豆的容器里。我知道我想出了各种方法来处理这些果冻豆。当然，这些镜头都没有被采用，但这只是我们当时玩的一个有趣的小花梗。那么我们现在要进入会议室了吗，
Angela? Oh yeah, because somebody needs to pass the tardy sauce. Yes, the entire sales team is assembled in the conference room and Dwight comes in late. So Andy is such a tool. Oh my gosh. So at the beginning of this scene, Michael explains that this is his dream team. This is my dream sales team and we're going to pair up and go on some sales calls. And we had a fan question from Holly Anderson. Holly Anderson says, Phyllis blows her nose right after Michael says, this is my dream team. Was that scripted? I wondered the same thing because it's brilliant. The timing is so perfect. It's so perfect. Yes, it was scripted. Amazing. Here is the script direction. Quote, the camera pans to board faces of the sales team. Phyllis blows her nose.
安吉拉？哦，对，因为有人需要递番茄酱了。是的，整个销售团队都在会议室集合了，而德怀特迟到了。所以安吉拉，安迪真是个讨厌鬼。哦，天哪。所以在这个场景的开头，迈克尔解释说这是他的梦之队。这是我的梦之团队，我们要两两配对去进行一些销售拜访。我们收到了来自霍莉·安德森的粉丝提问。霍莉·安德森说，迈克尔刚说完“这是我的梦之队”后，菲利斯就擤了鼻涕。那是剧本里写的吗？我也想知道同样的问题，因为实在是太绝了。时机把握得太完美了。太完美了。是的，那是剧本里写的。太神奇了。剧本上的指导是这样的。引述：“镜头切到销售团队面无表情的脸上。菲利斯擤了鼻涕。”
And you know, I got a guys, I this is a little moment because I watched it several times. It's so great. Phyllis gets out her little tissue. She sniffles a little bit and then she blows her nose. Like she times it perfectly, but she starts the bit a little early. And I think that's what sells making it look so organic. It's, it's really wonderful work. Little details. Phyllis, man, with the tissue work. So everyone gets paired up. Yes, we get Karen and Phyllis and Ryan and Stanley, Dwight and Jim and Michael and Andy. Now they're going to go out and be in cars together all day. I couldn't wait. I remember when we got the script in the table read, when I saw like the groupings, I was like, oh, this is going to be so fun.
你知道的，我看了好几遍，这真是一个绝妙的小细节。太棒了。菲利斯拿出了她的纸巾。她轻轻吸了吸鼻子，然后擤了鼻涕。就像她的时机掌握得恰到好处，但她稍微提前了一点点开始这个动作。我觉得正是这一点让它看起来如此自然有机。这真的是非常精彩的表演。细节见真章。菲利斯，天哪，纸巾的戏份太到位了。所以每个人都配对成功了。是的，我们有凯伦和菲利斯、瑞恩和斯坦利、德怀特和吉姆，还有迈克尔和安迪。现在他们要一起坐一整天的车出门了。我等不及了。我记得当我们拿到剧本进行围读时，当我看到分组时，我就想：哦，这肯定太有趣了。
Well, there's a Ryan talking head in here that makes me laugh so hard. Because you are now Ryan in real life. I am now Ryan. I love it that he said he's flattered to be Stanley's second choice after pass. After pass. Stanley got to pick his partner and his first response was pass. And his second response was, I guess I'll take the kid. Well, I wanted to talk really quickly about Jim's talking head. He holds up that photo of Dwight and Jim, like the old photo, because they clearly, they clearly have been on a ton of sales calls together, right? And it shows their history a little bit, which I love. But in the DVD commentary,
这里有一个瑞恩的谈话访谈，把我笑得不行。因为你现在就是现实生活中的瑞恩。我就是瑞恩。我太喜欢他说的话了，他说很荣幸能成为斯坦利在帕斯之后的第二选择。帕斯之后。斯坦利得挑选他的搭档，他的第一反应是“帕斯（拒绝）”。而他的第二反应是：“我想我只能选这个小伙子了。”我想要快速聊聊吉姆的谈话访谈。他举起了那张德怀特和吉姆的照片，就像老照片一样，因为他们显然一起进行过无数次销售拜访，对吧？这稍微展示了他们过去的历史，我很喜欢。但在DVD评论音轨中，
Rain said that his hair in that photo was from 1991. He was on tour with an acting company doing Romeo and Juliet, and they all had long Elizabethan hair. And they sort of, they sort of like photoshopped it onto current Dwight, but they left that big hair. I just thought it was hilarious. I love that detail. I know. So now they're all in the parking lot. They're paired up into their teams. They're about to get in their cars and go. Michael tosses Dwight his dirty laundry, which is a callback to the coup. I love it when our show does this. And we have a few in this episode, but this is a callback to the coup. And now he tells them all to circle up and he's going to give them their marching orders. Yeah. So then Michael
雷恩说他在那张照片里的头发是1991年的。他当时正跟一个剧团巡演，排演《罗密欧与朱丽叶》，他们所有人都有长长的伊丽莎白时代的头发。他们有点像，把那个发型P到了现在的德怀特头上，但保留了那一头长发。我当时觉得这简直太搞笑了。我太喜欢这个细节了。我知道。所以现在他们都在停车场里。他们两两组队。正准备上车出发。迈克尔把他的脏衣服扔给德怀特，这致敬了《政变》。我太喜欢我们剧里做这种彩蛋了。我们这一集里有好几个这样的彩蛋，但这一个是在致敬《政变》。现在他让大家围成一圈，准备下达指令。是的，接着迈克尔
says, guys, let's, let's go out on our sales calls. This is, it's like the, we're the amazing race. And everyone's like, how are we the amazing race? Is there a prize? He's like, no, there's no prize, but we're the amazing race. And he keeps, gives everybody these team names. And everyone's very confused. And then Michael just gets frustrated. He's like, just go on your sales call. But I love that he brought up the amazing race. This was a really, really popular reality show at the time. And I was a huge fan. Jenna, we were so into it. I remember you and I watching the amazing race. And then Jenna, do you remember how you and I were like, we should go on? We should be a team on amazing race together. I stand by that. I think we should.
说：“伙计们，我们出发去拜访客户吧。这就像是，我们正在参加《极速前进》。”每个人都一脸茫然地问：“我们怎么就成了《极速前进》了？有奖品吗？”他说：“没有，没有奖品，但我们就是《极速前进》。”接着他给每个人都起了这些团队名称。大家都非常困惑。然后迈克尔只好泄气地说：“总之去拜访客户就行了。”但我很喜欢他提到了《极速前进》。这是当时非常、非常受欢迎的一个真人秀节目。我曾是个超级粉丝。詹娜，我们当时太迷这个了。我还记得你和我一起看《极速前进》。然后詹娜，你还记得你和我当时怎么说的吗？我们应该去参加！我们应该一起去《极速前进》当一队。我坚持这个想法。我觉得我们真的应该去。
I think we, we would have been amazing. I think we would have been a total mess. Why? Why? Because I think you would be like, let's go, let's go. And I'd be like, can we just take a break? Maybe we'll have a glass of wine. And you'd be like, also, I can't eat any of that gross stuff, lady. I can't eat the gross stuff. Well, this is the problem. I think we would both have some of the same weaknesses. I think we couldn't eat the gross stuff. And maybe neither one of us would have great upper body strength for some of the like things where you have to like, like toss bales of hay down a maze or something. How about zero upper body strength? Yeah, zero. So maybe we wouldn't have been such a great team, but we would have had fun.
我觉得我们会表现得很惊艳。我觉得我们会把事情搞得一团糟。为什么？为什么？因为我觉得你会说：“我们走吧，我们走吧。”而我会说：“我们能不能休息一会儿？也许我们可以喝杯红酒。”然后你就会说：“还有，我绝对吃不下那些恶心的东西，亲爱的。我吃不下恶心的东西。”好吧，这就是问题所在。我觉得我们俩会有一些相同的弱点。我觉得我们都吃不下那些恶心Е的东西。而且也许我们俩在上半身力量方面都不太行，无法应付那些需要把干草捆扔过迷宫之类的任务。上半身力量为零怎么样？对，为零。所以也许我们不会成为一个那么棒的团队，但我们会玩得很开心。
I think we would have had fun. I think we would have had one colossal meltdown and then a fight. And then we would have cried. And then we'd laugh hysterically. We'd look like crazy people, but we would have had fun. I tell you what, we would have been good TV. Oh my God, we would have been great TV. Okay, okay. Well, we actually asked Greg about this amazing race moment. And here's what he had to say. The comparison to amazing race was fun because it's a reality. We were a reality based comedy show. It was a lot easier for the visual look of the show to be able to try and do references to other reality shows rather than movies, for instance. So there's like a Titanic reference in Booze Cruise. But I don't think it works as visually well as
我觉得我们会玩得很开心。我觉得我们会经历一次崩溃大哭，然后吵一架。接着我们会哭。然后我们会笑得前仰后合。我们会看起来像疯子一样，但我们会玩得很开心的。我跟你说，我们绝对是很好的电视素材。哦，天哪，我们绝对是绝佳的电视素材。好吧，好吧。其实我们问过格雷格关于这个《极速前进》梗的想法。以下是他的回答。《极速前进》的这个比较很有趣，因为它是一个真人秀。我们是一部基于真人秀风格的喜剧。相比电影而言，让节目的视觉风格去模仿其他真人秀节目要容易得多。所以在《酒后巡航》里有一个《泰坦尼克号》的致敬。但我认为它在视觉上没有这里的
an amazing race reference for here. Yeah, it totally makes sense to me, though. I think Michael is such a fan of pop culture and television and film. Like he wants any opportunity for his documentary of this paper company, whatever this is, this camera crew that follows him around. He thinks he's on par with the entertainment of the day. Yes, yes. Well, so now everyone gets in their cars and we kind of start driving around. And Angela, speaking of driving, we had a lot of questions about how we pulled off these driving shots. Amy Jackson, Deandre Tessone, Holly E, TJ McMillan, William Burke, and many more people all asked, how did filming work for the driving scenes? Are you guys actually driving or is there a green screen? What cameras were used in the car
《极速前进》梗效果那么好。是的，不过这对我来说完全说得通。我觉得迈克尔是个流行文化、电视和电影的超级粉丝。他希望找到任何机会，让这个关于纸业公司的纪录片——不管这到底是什么——这个跟拍他的摄像团队。他觉得自己可以和当下的娱乐节目相提并论。是的，是的。好吧，现在每个人都上了车，然后我们差不多开始开车上路了。而安吉拉，说到开车，我们有很多关于我们是如何拍出这些开车镜头的提问。艾米·杰克逊、迪安德雷·泰松、霍莉·E、TJ·麦克米伦、威廉·伯克以及许多其他人都在问：开车场景是怎么拍的？你们是真的在开车吗还是用了绿幕？车内场景
scenes? And are the actors really driving around? Well, first of all, the actors really are driving around. That is not a green screen. And then we went to Greg and we asked him to talk a little bit about what it was like to shoot people in the cars. And here's what he had to say. And one of the things I had noticed in production was how easy it was to shoot in a car for our show. You just basically put the two characters in the car and set up lipstick cameras and drove around and improvised a lot. And so the idea for traveling salesmen was we could get a lot of production value out of getting out of the office and it wouldn't be too hard for us to do. We just tricked out these cars and they would go off. So we have a little lingo alert there when Greg talks about lipstick
用了什么摄像机？演员们是真的在开车到处跑吗？首先，演员们确实是在开车。那不是绿幕。然后我们去找格雷格，请他谈谈在车里拍摄人们是什么感觉。以下是他的回答。我在制作过程中注意到的一件事，就是在我们的节目中在车里拍摄是多么容易。你基本上只需要把两个角色放进车里，安装上口红摄像头，然后开着车到处走，进行大量的即兴表演。所以《外勤推销员》的想法就是，我们可以通过离开办公室获得大量的制作价值，而且对我们来说也不会太难。我们只是把这些车改装了一下，然后他们就出发了。所以当格雷格提到口红摄像头时，我们这里有一个小行话警报。
cameras. Those are itty bitty tiny cameras that they would put up in our visors in the car at an angle and one would shoot one passenger and one would shoot the other passenger. And we would just literally do what Greg said. We would just drive around and we would have a little walkie-talkie in the car. And there would be a car either in front of us or behind us that had the crew, the director, a sound person. They could hear us. They could see us on a little like mobile video screen. And they would talk to us over the walkie-talkie and they would say, oh, that was great. We're going to do that again. And then we would just drive around. They would have police cars. Remember the police cars, Ange? Yeah, we had like the motorcycle police guys too
who would sort of be in the front and we'd have this path that was cleared for us so that, you know, we wouldn't have to drive around people who didn't know we were filming, right? So it was safe. And we would just basically make a loop usually in one neighborhood. We'd just make the same loop over and over. Yeah, that was the whole thing that Kent Sabornak, a.k.a. Kentopedia, he would have to clear that. He'd have to call the highway patrol or the police and they would give us a zone that we were allowed to use for a certain period of time on that day. And we would just loop around. And it was always difficult in Los Angeles to find a loop that didn't have any palm trees. So we tend to film in the same neighborhoods over and over because clearly they found trees that
looked possibly east coast-ish, you know? Yes. We got to know these loops very well. One of the things Dave Rogers said in the DVD commentary is that this was the first time that we used the lipstick cameras in the cars. Previously, when we had done driving scenes, one of our camera operators, Randall or Matt, would be scrunched in the back seat with a camera. And you know, I noticed the video quality was a little different on the lipstick cameras when I was watching it. It's not quite as crisp as a Matt camera or a Randall camera. Look at you, Miss Techie. You got a tech alert there? Look at you. I noticed it. I did. So let's talk about all of these cars and all they're driving around. Well, the first scene we really see
is Andy and Michael. And Andy is determined to use this one-on-one time with Michael to chip away at Dwight, right? He's going to undermine him. He asks about the laundry. Michael tells him that Dwight went to corporate to try to get his job. And oh my gosh, Andy is like so happy to get this information. Yes. He's going to spend this whole episode slowly chipping away at Dwight's reputation. Yeah. Well, then we see Phyllis. She pulls into a beauty salon. Her and Karen are going to get some super glam makeovers. We don't know why. It looks like when you used to go to the mall to glamour shots. Did you ever do that? I never did glamour shots, but my sister Emily did. Yes, I never did it either, but my sister Tina did. And they gave her this enormous hairdo, like this
bouffant hairdo and all this makeup. And I think like a feather boa. That was common. That was common. And they would shoot you on a green screen and then sort of insert different backgrounds, if I remember correctly. Like the Eiffel Tower. Yeah. Okay. So that is what this makeover looks like. That might be like an old tech alert. Does glamour shots still exist? I don't think so, lady. I don't think so. I think the era of the selfie and the iPhone, there aren't glamour. And the filters and the filters glamour shots are no more. Well, then we also have Ryan and Stanley. And Ryan asked Stanley if he could take the lead on the sales call. And Stanley is like, nothing would delight me more. Oh, Stanley knows something and he's tickled. He can't wait. Oh,
can't wait. We will find out why in a little bit. So now back at the office while all this driving around is happening, Angela invites Pam to coffee. Yes. And Pam was like, what? But okay. Now, on a personal note, I was thrilled to do this scene. You and I never got to do scenes together, let alone go on a location together. We were giddy, Jenna. We couldn't wait. So some of that smiling and happiness you see in Angela Martin is just me being happy that I get to do a scene with my BFF. And I get to be normal. I get to smile and not be snarky. It was so, we were so excited, Angela, when we got this script. Yeah. All of my scenes are basically with you. Yeah, we had the same work day. And then we had a few days off. It was like, we were like, woohoo. It was kind of
like BFF week. Yeah. For us. Well, some people pointed out that at the end of the scene, Pam grabs a notebook. And people were wondering, why is Pam bringing a notebook to coffee? Is she going to take notes on Angela? No. No, you guys, there was a line that got cut out. Pam says to Angela, you know what, I'll go around and take some coffee orders. I'll see, I'll see if anybody wants anything. Yes, this is in the deleted scene. She goes around, Meredith gets really angry at you. She's like, why would I pay $4 for milk and a cup? And she's like, it's all angry. Her creed get real cranky, right? Yeah, they get real cranky about the fancy coffee orders. And there is a scene, Jenna, that just won't break your heart because when we come back with a
coffee, it's clear that Toby only ordered coffee so he could have some interaction with Pam. But when she comes back with all the coffees and she's passing them around, she just hands it to Kelly, who then takes it to Toby. And Toby just looks at Pam through the glass partition from the annex, and he just, he just puts the coffee in the trash. He didn't even get to talk to her. Aw, Toby. Poor Toby. Toby. So sad. Well, Ange, in the script, there is a scene where Pam is taking Toby's coffee order. Oh yeah? That's not in the deleted scenes. Yeah. And he orders a chai latte and Pam says, oh my gosh, that's my coffee order. And he's like, oh, really? Oh, we have the same coffee order. Yeah. So not only does he not get his coffee
delivered by Pam, he ordered a coffee he didn't even really drink just to have something in common with her. Toby. He's stalking Pam and in love with her. So now you guys, we're in the parking lot and Dwight wants to amp himself up. He's got to get pumped for this sales call. Jim knows they have been on countless sales calls. He's like, you still do the thing. And Dwight's like, just give me the keys. And then he plays like, I don't know, is it like Motley Crue or something? And once again, we see, we see Dwight like rocking out doing air guitar to heavy metal, like punching the seat to get ready. Yes. Yeah. This is their, this is his routine, I guess. Yeah. And Jim knows it. They're like old roommates. He's like, here we go. I stand out here. He does
air guitar. So he is amped up because then when they're walking into the building, Dwight has to be Dwight and he's like, you go in first because he doesn't want to get attacked from behind. Seven out of 10 attacks are from the rear. Right. And Jim is like, well, what about the other 30% and Dwight's like, I'd block it. I'd block it. You can't get me. And then in like mid sentence, Jim just halls off and smacks Dwight and he is shocked. He can't believe he's been attacked from the front. He can't believe it. Also, he's about to break. Rain is about to laugh. You can totally see it at eight minutes, 50 seconds. Rain is about to laugh. Oh, 100%. 100%. Well, we had a fan question from Rachel Fortune. Was Jim supposed to slap
Dwight as they walk in the building because rain looked truly shocked? Well guys, this was a scripted moment, but there's a reason why rain was surprised even though it was scripted. And we asked Greg about it. Here's what he had to say. So some people asked about the Jim slapping Dwight moment. So, you know, it's fun to think of the two of them as being teamed up earlier in their career. And we gave it kind of an Abbott and Costello comedy team feel, you know, where Jim is like stopping short. So Dwight hits his head. And usually these little moments involve some comeuppance for Dwight. And I remember John came up to me right before we were going to shoot the part where he hits Dwight in the face. And he said that he wanted to hit rain for real a little bit
harder than they had worked out just to get a good startle out of him. And I can't recall whether rain was in on this, but just didn't want to know which take. But we kind of worked out which take he was going to do. And I'm pretty sure we used the one where rain was really startled that John had hit him. So here's the deal on the DVD commentary. Rain and John talk in depth about this moment. And Rain asked John to hit him harder. He was like, I want you to hit me hard. And here's the thing about rain. He's very method, you guys, when I slapped him, remember in Casino night, yeah, he said to me, and you got to slap me harder, really slap me. So in the DVD commentary, John was like, remember rain, you were like, slap me harder. And I was like, okay. And of course,
that's the take they use because rain was legitimately like, whoa. And then he almost started laughing. Well, you can totally tell that he was taken aback. Yeah. And it ends up making a scripted moment look unscripted. But it was definitely scripted. I remember it said something like Dwight gets smacked in the head by Jim. And you know, we would always have stunt coordinators come in anytime we had to put our hands on another actor, even if it was something that might be considered small like a slap. And they actually teach you how to hit someone with your palm in this certain sort of cupped way. So it makes a louder noise or it looks more violent than it really is. And so, you know, we always had that training in us as well. So I guess I should say, rain was
not hurt in the execution of this, but he was certainly shocked. Well, it worked and it cracked rain up and everyone else and that's the take they picked. So lady, where are we? Are we going into some sales calls? We are. We're about to go into all these sales meetings. But why don't we take a break and then we'll pick up right there in just a moment. Yeah. All right, we are back. Let's talk about all of these sales meetings. Yes, I think the first one is Michael and Andy. And Jenna, once again, we see that Michael is a good salesman. He knows how to connect with people. He really does. He really does. He doesn't know how to be someone's boss. That is his failing. He thinks that he's supposed to entertain you as a boss. Yeah,
but he does know how to connect with people one on one and he really connects with this guy over fishing. He compliments the fish that he caught. And it's a callback to Lake while in Pawpack. Love a callback. Love a callback. And then Andy's like, yeah, my dad has a Bayliner, whatever he says, I shot a shark. I mean, if you are a true fisherman, the idea of shooting a fish in any way is so off-putting. There's sort of an art to fishing and a lot of people even do like the throwback, you know, if they're fishing on a lake. So you could just tell this really was off-putting to this man. Angela, do you know all of that because of your ex-boyfriend that made you watch Bassmasters? Oh, God, you had to bring up. I want to tell you, Angela, after we talked about Bassmasters
on the podcast, they sent us each a little goodie bag of stuff. And one of the things that they sent us, it was so sweet. They just said, hey, thanks for talking about us. It was totally organic and random. But they sent me this journal. A leather bound journal. It's so nice. A leather bound journal. It says Bassmasters on it. And I love it. It is my new favorite journal. So now, because of your ex-boyfriend making you watch Bassmasters and you bringing it up on this podcast, I now journal in a Bassmasters journal. That is what has happened. Well, you're welcome. And Kyle says you're welcome. That was his name. Well, thank you, Kyle. Oh, no, it's out there. Oh, boy. Yeah. Well, Bassmasters sent me a hoodie that I love. And I walk around with my Bassmasters hoodie. Yeah. So
here's the thing. There's a great little moment in the DVD commentary about this scene where Ed says that he and Steve did go off script in this scene. And the actor that plays the man they're, you know, the business owner they're talking to was not really ready for them to go off script. He wasn't. Oh, dear. And he just gave them this sort of odd, quizzical look like, what are you talking about? And Dave Rogers is in this commentary and he goes, but it was perfect. So that look, you see this man giving Michael and Andy like what is really earnest. Oh my gosh, I love that. I love that tidbit. Well, guys, the actor who plays the client that Michael and Andy are talking to is named Warren Sweeney. So Warren, while you were surprised, your look worked. It totally worked.
Well, then we cut to the car and you can tell Michael is not pleased with Andy. But Andy turns it around. And he's like, I'm so sorry for screwing up our sales call. I really shrewd it. Yeah. That's what we say around the office when someone really screws up. We say they shrewd it. And then he's like, I wonder, wonder how that name came up. I wonder if it's because of Dwight. And Michael gives him nothing. Michael's like, well, who knows how words are formed. Like, he's not getting it. And Andy's getting so frustrated. Andy is planting all these seeds that Dwight is an idiot. And Michael is not getting it. It's awesome. So let's now talk about Phyllis and Karen's meeting. They get a very large order from this gentleman. Oh, this is my
St. Louis catch. All right. This is around. Okay. This is around 11 minutes, 33 seconds. And Phyllis goes, well, thanks. That's a big order. She doesn't say order. That's a big order. It says like Arder. Yeah, that's right in line with Fark. Oh, St. Louis catch. And then, and then she asked how his wife is doing. And he shows a photo of himself and his wife on vacation. And they look just like her. The same hair, the same makeup. And Karen's like, ah, I see what you're doing Phyllis. Very smart. Okay, we've got to talk about Dwight and Jim in their sales call, because Jenna, they clearly have a whole shtick. Yes. I loved it. It's so seamless. Yes. I want you to know my kids left so hard when Dwight, when he's making the call and he's going seven,
then three, if we're cracking up. Well, I don't know about you, Angela, but I hate those like robo call customer service lines so much that I just like immediately when they come up, I'm like agent speak to a speak to pharmacist agent. I won't even say any numbers. I'm like, I can't. I can't. Jenna, I have such a fond memory of my dad. It's weird, you know, when you when someone you love so much passes away. And I don't mean to be a Debbie Downer here in this moment, because this is a happy memory for me. But it's interesting that things your brain latches onto and holds dear things you would never, ever expect. But I have such a vivid memory of my dad on the phone with clearly like some kind of like robot. And he's, he's this, you know,
he was just this sweet cowboy, you know, Southern guy and he was going five. No. Yes. Talk to person, person. And then like whatever the password was, tractor, tractor. Oh, I love that, Ian. I love that you shared that. It made me think of him. It's weird. It's weird the way your brain works like that, your brain and your heart. Okay. So yes. So Dwight is doing this call. We don't know who he's calling and Jim presses on with his sales pitch, right? Yeah, through all of this. And the guy is like, listen, I don't know what to tell you. I mean, I just maybe feel more comfortable
with the with a bigger company with one of the big guys. And they're like, well, is customer service important to you? And he's like, it's very important. And he's like, well, we've been on hold with the customer service department of a big company. Oh, and there's the switch. Aha. There was a whole purpose. And then he calls Dunder Mifflin customer service and Kelly answers. I was like, Hey, what are you guys doing? Yes. Yes. So amazing. And then the guy is like sold sold you my business sold and Dwight handsome his business card. And Jenna, I love what's on Dwight's business card, his cell number, his pager number, his home number, and his other pager number. Yeah. And then he says, I take no days off. I've never been sick. And I don't celebrate any
major holidays. And he's like, Okay, okay, I got it. Interesting tech alert. His email was not on his business card, Jenna. Nowadays, I think your email would be on there. For sure. For sure. But we shot this in the Stone Age. So now Ryan and Stanley go into the church for their sales call. And these four older, very sort of like dignified black men and their suits walk out to him. They're clearly an older generation. They're Stanley's generation. And there's this young white kid who Jenna, I don't think I don't think Ryan's been in the church in a while. No. And we've established that the way all these sales calls are successful is by people connecting with their client in some personal way. And we quickly see that Ryan is going to have a hard time connecting
with these gentlemen. And he just sort of starts stammering. And he just keeps introducing himself over and over again. Hi. Hi. Hi. Hi. And I love that Stanley's like, I'm not helping you. In fact, I'm just going to ignore you. I'm going to turn away and do my crossword and let you just what's the expression to know where just you flap in the way in the wind. Yeah, something like that. He's just going to hang them out to dry there. It's so good. I was able to find out the names of two of the clients, but I couldn't find names for the other guys. But Landon H. Lewis Jr. and Leon Simmons Jr. are two of the clients in that scene. I also loved how all of the men in the scene were so much taller than BJ. Yes. Because it really also made him just look so young,
you know? Yeah. Next to them, just the size difference. Yes. And then later when they're in the car, Angela, Stanley cannot stop laughing. There are all these shots that go back to them driving back to Dunder Mifflin and Stanley is just like, can't believe he's so delighted by how that went. He's so tickled. It clearly made his day. I don't know that Stanley gets much joy out of working at Dunder Mifflin, but this was a real highlight for him. And there's this moment that Leslie talks about in the DVD. He said in the script, it was just that Stanley is driving and laughing and they just kind of let him go. And he improvised the whole thing about, hi, hi, you sounded like my six month old niece. And like all of that, Leslie was just riffing.
Oh, that was so good. I know. And he said, in fact, whenever Stanley would go off on Ryan, as he has throughout the show, they would just let Leslie just go. And I think there's some amazing moments. Oh, yes. Yes. Well, you know, and this is Ryan's second sales call now that has not gone well. Remember, he went on the initiation sales call with Dwight. They did not make the sale. And now he's gone out on this call with Stanley. Now I believe Stanley is going to save this sale. Oh, Stanley for sure saved it. Okay. So while all of these sales meetings are happening, Pam and Angela are at the coffee shop. Angela is in such a great mood. And she's telling Pam a story about how she had this friend who was in need. And this gallant man came to her rescue.
Yeah. She's like, he must really care for her a lot. Because he did this wonderful thing for my friend. Yeah, she's talking in code. She's speaking in code. She's like, my friend, let's let's call her Noel. And this gallant gentleman will call him Kurt. Well, we all know that Kurt is Dwight's middle name, right? Yes. And we got a lot of fan questions about this, Angela. Kenzie B, Elizabeth R, Julia Lee, Nicole Fink and Katie Krull all want to know when Angela refers to her friend Noel. Is that because Noel is Angela's middle name? It definitely sounds like a very Angela Martin middle name. Well, yes, it is Angela's middle name. Angela thinks she's being really savvy. But Pam totally knows who she's talking about. But yes, that is
her middle name. But Jenna, I have a question for you. Okay. Is Noel in the script? Because I have a little story about that middle name. And I'm curious. I think what was in the script was Colette. Okay, I looked this up. And in the script, Angela actually says this. She says, well, a friend of mine, let's just call her, oh, let's just call her me. What? And then you giggle. Okay. So my memory of this is when we were shooting it that day, that the writers were pitching me different middle names, like different things to say. I know in one of them it was Colette. I have such a memory of saying that. And, and then we said Noel. And I like Noel the best because it sounds very sort of Angela Martin, doesn't it? Her love of Christmas, her love of the story of
Christmas, that Noel would be her middle name. And that's the one we went with. And Dave Rogers talks about it in the DVD commentary. And he goes, I remember it being Colette. And he thought maybe I improvised Noel, but I didn't. That was a writer's pitch. I mean, I think I was part of the dialogue. I think we were pitching names. But that all sort of happened in the moment. I love it. It's perfect. It is perfect. Angela Noel Martin. And I believe that will appear on your wedding invitation. Oh, yeah. It's now, it's now part of my character's show Bible. We had another fan catch in this scene, Angela. Sarah Rouse wrote in to say, Pam is holding a piece of paper at the coffee shop. What is that supposed to be? And what does it say?
Well, Sarah, that was the list of coffee orders from those deleted scenes. I had all the coffee orders written down on that piece of paper and I was going to use it to make my order. Well, Angela, also in this scene, just because we were talking about it earlier, your flower hairdo is on full display. Just if you really want some great shots of it guys, here it is, her WTF hairdo right here. WTF. Well, wait, wait, I have something to share. So while we were on a break, I had been texting Kim Ferry about this hair and she texted back. And so this is what she had to say about it. I said, Oh my gosh, it's a real time tidbit. It's a real time tidbit. It just came in a few minutes ago. I said, Kim, what was the inspiration
for this bun? I mean, I know that we thought my character was going to like be in a great mood. And so we wanted to try something new. She said, Yes, here is the inspiration. She said, my first job in the business was working on a sci-fi show called Babylon 5. I worked on this show for five years and I couldn't use any contemporary hairstyles because they wanted the hairstyles to look futuristic. So I started coming up with all these different kind of braids and and buns with wires and fancy updos and Zulu knots, basically anything different that I could think of. And your bun with those fun swirls was a good one for me because I had done it on Babylon 5. It's fast and easy. But technically, this is a sci-fi hairstyle. Oh my gosh. Isn't that
great? Don't you feel like Dwight would have loved it because he was Mr. Sci-Fi? Yes. Yes. No wonder she did her hair in this Babylon 5 hairstyle to thank Dwight for his like favor. Yeah. So yes, this hairstyle inspired by Babylon 5. It's the sci-fi bun. I don't think I could love that more. Kim Ferry, thank you for the real-time tidbit. Thank you, Kim Ferry. Sam just wrote Beats, Bears, Babylon 5. Beats. Oh wait, here we go. Bears, Beats, Babylon 5 buns. Oh, okay. So now everybody is coming back from their sales calls. Everyone's done. And we have this amazing scene in the car with Karen and Phyllis. Phyllis is so good in this scene because you guys, she is going to reveal such a big plot point
and she just throws it away, right? It's not like belabored in any way. It's so perfect. Yeah. She's like, Karen, I had a lot of fun with you today. I really enjoy spending time with you. They're bonding. They feel good. And then she just very offhandedly says, and I'm really glad you're with Jim. That makes me really happy because, you know, he was really hung up on Pam for such a long time. And she's not even looking at Karen. She's looking in a rearview mirror. She's turning. She's just driving. She's just sort of saying something off the cuff and it's that much more powerful. And then Rashida, oh my gosh, her reaction is so perfect. It's a fantastic scene. Fantastic scene. I feel like her pulse
stops for a second. Like, I feel like I can see the wind go out of her. Right? Yes, I do too. You just, you see it hit her like a freight train, but she can't react. Yeah. The way it's really hitting her. It's so well done. These ladies did such a great job. I agree. Yes. Well, Andy is the first person to actually get back to the office. And he starts, he starts sneaking around Dwight's desk. He goes through his car. Yeah, Andy is a total snake. I mean, what the heck? I know. And he finds this toll booth receipt that proves that Dwight was in New York this morning. He didn't oversleep like he claimed. And he marches into Michael's office and he's like, I found this toll booth receipt. I wonder what he was doing. Was he, maybe he was
talking to Jan. And then he says like, I seem to kind of remember, I don't know who told me this, even though Jenna, this was like, like an hour ago. He's like, I don't know who told me this. It was something. And then he has maybe one of my favorite quotes of this episode. He was like, there's a story. I don't know. It was about laundry and betrayal. In my mind, this is now a lifetime movie called Laundry and Betrayal. I want to see it. Yes. Yes. Laundry and Betrayal. I want to see this film. I do too. Well, so Michael calls Jan. And Jan is like, well, I didn't speak to Dwight, but he did not give a reason for why he was here. Yes. This is my kid's favorite part. My kid's favorite part is Jan goes, he did sign into the security sign-in sheet. But
under state your business, he wrote beeswax, not yours incorporated. I love that too. My kids loved that. Well, when Dwight gets back to the office, Michael confronts him. He's like, where were you? Tell me where you were. And Dwight will not say. He won't say where he was. He overslept. The damn rooster didn't grow. Yeah. But he will not, he will not fess up. And this becomes a problem. And Pam knows why. Pam and Angela are exchanging looks. Angela is sweating it. She's horrified that Dwight's going through this, but she doesn't want people to know about them. It's very layered emotionally for Angela. Well, it leads to a breakroom scene with Dwight and Angela, where you are again, not facing one another, one of your famous,
famous breakroom scenes. There's a little bit of heartbreak in the breakroom in this scene. Oh, lady, I noticed it too. Here's what we had. That was by Michelle Ferguson. Michelle, you know how much we love that song. We love it. Yeah. I literally listen to it all the time. It's super catchy. It's very catchy. I really love it. Someone give this woman a music contract. We'll buy it. Okay. We love it. Yeah. So Dwight is like, listen, why don't we just come clean and, you know, let people know our love for one another. So this scene actually went on. It's not in the deleted scenes, but we did shoot a little bit longer version where as I cry behind me, Dwight's like, don't cry, monkey. Monkeys, don't cry. Oh, I kind of wish that was still in there.
I know. I know. Well, Angela, a few people wrote in about this scene because they noted that when you start dating Andy, you have no problem with everyone in the office knowing it. Oh, well, Angela revenge dates Andy, you guys. Andy is not her true love that she wants to protect and keep all to herself because it's so special. She's starting to date Andy because she's mad as hell at Dwight. Right. Very different motivation. Right. In the meantime, Karen and Jim have gone to coffee and Karen is going to ask Jim if he had feelings for Pam. And lady, I have a clip. Sam, play the clip because everything you need to know is right here, Karen. Why couldn't you hear it? Let me ask you a question. Okay. Do you ever have a thing for Pam?
Pam? Did I ever have a thing for her? No. Why did she do something? It's so clear. That's all you need to know, Karen. He clearly has a thing for her, but oh, poor Karen. She, you know, he convinces her that he doesn't. Maybe he's not ready to admit it. Right. And she is not ready to really see truth, but you know, down deep, she knows. Well, lady, she says, I moved here. Yeah. I moved here. And I think that's the part of Karen that doesn't want to see the truth because it's a little humiliating to deal with the fact that you moved somewhere for the wrong person. Exactly. We all have a friend who has moved somewhere for someone, and then it didn't work out. It's devastating. But then they hang on to it because they moved.
帕姆？我以前对她有过感觉吗？没有。为什么她做了什么？这太明显了。这就是你需要知道的全部，凯伦。他明显对她有感觉，但哦，可怜的凯伦。你知道的，他向她保证他没有。也许他还没准备好承认。没错。她也没有准备好真正面对现实，但你知道，内心深处，她是知道的。好吧，女士，她说，我搬到这儿来了。对。我搬到这儿来了。我想这就是凯伦不愿面对现实的那部分，因为处理这样一个事实：你为了错误的人搬到某个地方，这有点羞辱性。没错。我们都有一个朋友，为了某人搬到某个地方，结果却泡汤了。这太打击人了。但他们还是紧抓不放，因为他们已经搬了。
Yeah. And it's like you want, you're willing it to be right, even though you know it's wrong. So this is the moment where I know we've been coming down kind of hard on wishy washy Jim, but this is the moment where Karen is now not reading the signals. No, no. So, Ange, should we go back to Dunder Mifflin to this grand announcement from Dwight? Yes. I mean, he makes this huge like speech and basically he's like, I'm quitting. So I quit. Yeah. He quits. Rather than reveal his secret about his relationship with Angela and where he was this morning, he quits. Dwight leaves. He gives Michael his box of things. He does keep his Dwight bobblehead. I'll let you know. Of course. There is a deleted scene where he goes
对。这就好像你想，你强迫自己相信这是对的，尽管你知道这是错的。所以，这是个时刻，我知道我们对优柔寡断的吉姆有点严厉了，但这就是凯伦现在没有察觉到信号的时刻。不，不。所以，安吉，我们要不要回到邓德米夫林，听听德怀特这个重大的宣布？是的。我的意思是，他发表了一场巨大的演讲，基本上就是，我要辞职了。所以我辞职了。对。他辞职了。为了不泄露他与安吉拉的恋情秘密以及他今天早晨去了哪里，他辞职了。德怀特离开了。他把他的东西箱交给了迈克尔。他确实留下了他的德怀特摇头娃娃。我得让你知道。当然。有一个被删掉的场景，他四处走动
around and gives us all items from the box Jenna. It's very funny. I remember shooting that. Yeah. And then he walks out and he does his salute. It's the same salute from the initiation. Nice little call back there. And Dwight is gone. Yeah. And Angela, he has a line that, oh my gosh, he says in a talking head as he's leaving, there's this line where he said, I really believed I was going to die in that chair that he was so committed to Dunder Mifflin, he thought he would die in his sales chair. I mean, oh, I have no doubt that's ultimately how it ends for Dwight someday. If the series would have gone. Yeah. In fan fiction, if you write the end, I see Dwight's funeral like, you know, have you ever heard of these, these funeral homes that would stage family
并把箱子里的东西送给我们每个人，珍娜。太搞笑了。我记得当时拍的那场戏。对。然后他走了出去，行了个军礼。和入职仪式上的是同一个军礼。真是个美好的小回忆。然后德怀特就走了。对。而且安吉拉，他有一句台词，哦天哪，他在离开时做单采时说的一句话，有这样一句台词，他说，我真的相信我会死在那把椅子上，他太忠于邓德米夫林了，他以为他会死在他的销售椅上。我是说，哦，我毫不怀疑这最终会是德怀特某天的结局。如果剧集还能继续的话。对。在同人小说里，如果你写结局，我能看到德怀特的葬礼就像是，你知道的，你听说过这些殡仪馆会安排家庭成员摆出他们最喜欢的活动姿势吗？不，我从来没有，我从来没听说过一个人被摆成他最喜欢的活动姿势的葬礼。
members doing their favorite activity? No, I have never, I have never heard of a funeral where a person is staged doing their favorite activity. So like, for example, if you love fishing, since we've been talking about fishing, yes, the person would be staged like in a boat with a fishing rod. Yes, I saw a show. I saw a show all about it. Don't ask me. I think I was like just channel surfing, looking for something. But like, it's like a thing you can get and they have devices that prop people up and things. But like, let's say you love surfing, you'd be posing on your surfboard. It's a real thing. And then instead of like a wake where they come and view the body and you're in the casket, like, and you say you're goodbye, you're on your surfboard.
所以，比如说，如果你喜欢钓鱼，既然我们一直在谈论钓鱼，是的，这个人会被摆成坐在船上拿着鱼竿的姿势。对，我看到过一个节目。我看到一个全关于这个的节目。别问我。我想我当时只是在换台，随便找点什么看。但这就好像是你可以得到的一种服务，他们有装置把人撑起来什么的。但比如说，如果你喜欢冲浪，你就会在冲浪板上摆姿势。这是真的。然后，不是像那种大家来瞻仰遗体、你躺在棺材里、然后你说再见的守灵，你是在你的冲浪板上。
Well, if it were me, I guess I would be propped up maybe watching TV, eating a bowl of frozen yogurt or making bread. And you can come say goodbye to me. I'd be, you know, hanging my hummingbird feeder and holding a glass of wine, I guess. Oh, Angela, now I want this for your funeral. If I outlive you, if I outlive you, I am going to pose you with a hummingbird feeder in one hand and a glass of rosé in the other. And I'm going to come say goodbye to you. I will talk to you for hours. Please have it be a real hummingbird feeder with real hummingbird food and maybe they'll come take a drink while I'm standing there. Oh, please. Okay, okay. Done and done. So yes, I guess your point was that perhaps Dwight's funeral, he would have been staged at
好吧，如果是我，我想我可能会被撑起来看电视、吃一碗冷冻酸奶或者做面包。然后你可以来跟我说再见。我大概会，你知道的，挂着我的蜂鸟喂食器，手里拿一杯酒。哦，安吉拉，现在我希望你的葬礼也这样。如果我比你活得长，如果我比你活得长，我要让你摆出这样一个姿势：一只手拿着蜂鸟喂食器，另一只手拿着一杯桃红葡萄酒。然后我要来跟你说再见。我要跟你聊上好几个小时。请一定要是一个真的蜂鸟喂食器，里面有真的蜂鸟食，也许在我站着的时候它们会来喝一口。哦，拜托。好吧，好吧。一言为定。所以，是的，我想你的意思是，也许德怀特的葬礼，他会被摆在
his Dunder Mifflin desk. Okay. Taking a sales call. Wow. At the funeral home, there's even a lookbook that you can flip through. Oh yeah, I'll take exhibit A at the desk typing on the keyboard pose. Wow. I feel like you could do some real passive aggressive stuff with this. Like whoever is in charge of your funeral. You could be like, oh, you want to know Larry's favorite activity? I'll tell you what it was. It was Marjorie. I was going to say it was so I posed him holding his. God, why is that cracking me up so much? It would be like when people come for the funeral, they're like, what is going on? And we're like, Larry's favorite activity being a to Marjorie online. Yeah. So there it is.
他的邓德米夫林办公桌前。好的。接听销售电话。哇。在殡仪馆里，甚至还有一本你可以翻阅的造型手册。哦，是的，我要选展品A：坐在桌前打字的造型。哇。我觉得你可以用这个做一些真正被动攻击的事情。比如谁负责你的葬礼。你可以说，哦，你想知道拉里的最爱活动是什么吗？我来告诉你那是什么。那是玛乔丽。我本来想说那是，所以我把他摆成拿着他的。天哪，为什么这让我笑得这么厉害？这就像人们来参加葬礼时，他们会问，到底是怎么回事？而我们会说，拉里的最爱活动是在网上对玛乔丽。对。所以就是这样。
That's Marjorie. Bye. That's Marjorie's picture on the computer. That's him holding a shmini. I paid $5,000 for this. F*** you, Larry. Oh my God. Oh my goodness. Okay, listen. And me while Marjorie's like, I didn't know anyone knew. I don't know. My God, Marjorie's husband, Joe is like super shocked. He's like Marge. What's up? Hey, it's all in laundry and betrayal on lifetime. We just wrote our script, lady. The big reveal at the funeral. Okay. Okay. Okay. So now, now we have this. We have to get it together. Okay. Oh my God. Okay. Now we have this amazing Andy talking head. It's a Willy Wonka callback. It's awesome.
那是玛乔丽。再见。那是电脑上玛乔丽的照片。那是他拿着一个微型三脚架。我为此付了五千亿美元。去你的，拉里。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。好吧，听着。与此同时，玛乔丽却在想，我不知道有人知道。我不知道。天哪，玛乔丽的丈夫乔超级震惊，他像是在说，马奇。怎么了？嘿，这简直是Lifetime频道的出轨与背叛剧码。我们刚刚写好了剧本，女士。葬礼上的大反转。好吧。好吧。好吧。所以现在，现在我们有了这个。我们得把它拍出来。哦，天哪。好吧。现在我们有了这个精彩的安迪单采。这是对《查理和巧克力工厂》的致敬。太棒了。
It goes a little something like oompa loompa dippity domm. Dwight is now gone, which is totally awesome. Yeah. I was like, who wrote this talking head? Who wrote this? So good. And in the DVD commentary, they said it was Mike. Sure. Oh, there you go. Yeah. Ed said that Mike was in the room with him when he was doing his talking head and they were riffing around. And, and they found this one and it's so, it's so perfect. And then of course, Angela, in the background of this talking head, the camera finds you hovering in the background, giving a death stare. Oh yeah. Death stare. I remember this so vividly. So Greg was like, Angela, I really want you to glare, like really be angry. Just like Andy is going down. You hate him glare at him.
它的节奏有点像：翁帕娄帕嘀嘀笃，德怀特现在走啦，这真的超酷。对。我当时想，是谁写的这段单采？谁写的？太棒了。在DVD评论音轨里，他们说是迈克写的。没错。哦，原来如此。对，埃德说迈克在他做单采时就在房间里，他们一起即兴创作。然后，他们找到了这一段，而且它如此、如此完美。然后当然，安吉拉，在这个单采的背景中，镜头捕捉到你在背景里徘徊，投来死亡凝视。哦，是的。死亡凝视。我对此记忆犹新。所以格雷格说，安吉拉，我真的需要你怒目而视，真的要表现得很生气。就像安迪要完蛋了，你恨他，狠狠地瞪他。
So I did. And he came up to me and he was like, can you give me more? I was like, what? He was like, even harder. I want you to, I just need the death stare of all death stares. I did it again. He's like, Angela, even more. I wrote about it in my journal. I said, Greg kept saying one more time Angela, more mad, more by the end. My eyeballs were shaking in my head. I wrote down, Angela, did you get a headache? Yes. I had the sci fi bun. I was giving the super death stare. And truly by the end, I think you can ever so slightly see me shaking. That's how like angry my stare is that I'm like, I was curious if you like popped a blood vessel in your eyeball or something. It is so intense. I was about to. I'm not kidding. It is a great way
所以我照做了。他走到我面前说，你能再多来点吗？我当时想，什么？他说，还要更狠。我需要你，我只需要所有死亡凝视中最狠的那个。我又做了一次。他说，安吉拉，还要更多。我在日记里写下了这件事。我说，格雷格一直说再来一次，安吉拉，更生气，更生气。到最后，我的眼珠子在脑袋里直晃。我写道：安吉拉，你头痛了吗？是的。我梳着科幻小说里的发髻。我当时在施展超级死亡凝视。真的到最后，我想你甚至能微弱地看到我在发抖。我的眼神就是这么生气，以至于我当时在想，我很好奇你是不是在眼球里爆血管了什么的。太激烈了。我当时差点就爆了。我没开玩笑。这真的是结束
to end the episode. I do have a fan question, Angela. Okay. And I don't mean to unravel the entire plot of this show. What? But it's a good question. Okay. It comes from Grace D. And she says, why couldn't Angela just bring her own tax forms to corporate? She has too many cats, Grace. Well, and also we know from the deleted scenes, some one of her cats just had a litter of kittens that she's dealing with. That was my first thought to Angela. I was kind of stumped by that at first. And I was like, yeah, why didn't Angela just go to New York herself? But then I was like, no, she probably has, she probably gets up very early and has like a 90 minute cat routine she has to do every morning.
这一集的好方法。我确实有一个粉丝提问，安吉拉。好的。我不是故意要推翻这部剧的整个剧情。什么？但这是一个好问题。好的。它来自格蕾丝·D。她说，为什么安吉拉不能自己把税表带到总公司去？她有太多猫了，格蕾丝。好吧，而且我们也从被删减的场景中得知，她的其中一只猫刚刚生了一窝小猫，她正在处理这件事。那是我对安吉拉的第一反应。我一开始被那个难住了。我在想，对啊，为什么安吉拉不自己去纽约呢？但后来我想，不，她可能，她可能起得很早，每天早晨都有一套要花90分钟处理的猫咪日常流程。
Putting ointment on eyes and medicines and grooming, right? Yes. And getting the litter boxes ready for the day and setting out food for all of them. I think she has a full morning before she gets to work and especially if she had a litter of kittens. And I think she was probably stressing out and going through this whole list with Dwight and he just said, I'll take them. Don't worry. I'll do it. I'll do it. Yes. That's right. The choices for Dwight were take the forms to New York or do the cat care list. And he was like, I choose forms to New York. Yeah. But good question, Grace. I thought valid question, valid question, question. Well, lady, that is traveling salesman next week. We head into the return. Yes. And the return is the return for several people. And it's
给眼睛上药、喂药和梳理毛发，对吧？是的。为新的一天准备猫砂盆，并为它们所有人准备好食物。我想她在上班前有一整套繁重的早晨流程，特别是如果她有一窝小猫的话。我想她当时可能压力很大，正在和德怀特核对整个清单，而他只是说，我带去。别担心。我来。我来。没错。德怀特的选择要么是把表格带去纽约，要么是完成猫咪护理清单。而他当时说，我选把表格带去纽约。对。不过问得好，格蕾丝。我觉得是个好问题，好问题，好问题。好吧，女士，那是下一周的《旅行推销员》。我们要进入《回归》了。是的。而《回归》是几个人的回归。而且这
such a fun episode. So we will see you next week. All right. Bye, guys. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Errol, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubacow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是极其有趣的一集。所以我们下周见。好的。大家再见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由埃罗尔、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。想要无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码Office。本集尚无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。